[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días en france 24 este es
un magacín informativo 100 dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre es liliana
valencia aquí damos una mirada en
profundidad los hechos de actualidad de
la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
'el opositor' maliense soumaila cissé y
la trabajadora humanitaria francesa
sophie petrona quienes permanecían
secuestrados fueron liberados por al
qaeda al menos un centenar de yihadistas
fueron encarcelados a cambio de petrona
y cissé
décimo un nuevo acuerdo de paz entre
sudan del sur y varios grupos
insurgentes a pesar de que algunos se
mantuvieron al margen del acuerdo el
gobierno anunció que las fuerzas
militares se unificarán el próximo mes
de noviembre
y el presidente de madagascar andry
rajoelina presentó un nuevo medicamento
para tratar el codo y 19 se trata del cb
o plus una nueva versión del polémico
código orgánico desarrollado por
científicos del país insular
iniciamos entonces con la información in
africa siete días y empezamos en mali
donde se llevó a cabo la liberación del
político opositor sumaila sisej la
trabajadora humanitaria francesa sophie
petrona quienes estaban secuestrados por
militantes de al-qaeda veamos la
historia dos rehenes retenidos por
extremistas vinculados a al qaeda animal
y fueron liberados según las autoridades
malienses lo que estalló mediáticamente
en twitter fue que tanto la francesa
sophie y petrona como el político
maliense soumaila cissé ya estaban en
camino la libertad
el presidente de manuel macrón agradeció
a mali sophie petro con janis está libre
retenida durante cuatro años su
liberación es un gran alivio a su
familia y parientes les envía un mensaje
de simpatía a las autoridades de malí
gracias continúa la lucha contra el
terrorismo en el sahel también fueron
liberados dos italianos incluido un
sacerdote secuestrado en níger hace dos
años petronan una trabajadora
humanitaria de 75 años dirigía una
organización benéfica para niños
huérfanos y fue secuestrada en el norte
de mali en 2016
el político maliense soumaila cissé
también fue capturado el ex ministro que
se postuló dos veces
la presidencia fue secuestrado mientras
hacía campaña en marzo de este año esto
alimentó las protestas contra el
presidente del país
ibrahim abu bakr keita cuyo segundo
mandato llegó a su fin después de que
fue derrocado por los militares en
agosto la liberación se produce después
de que el ejército de mali que ahora
está a cargo de la transición hacia un
gobierno civil liberará a unos 130
extremistas durante el fin de semana
varios países de áfrica occidental han
levantado las sanciones que le habían
impuesto a mali después de que keita fue
derrocado
pues justamente eso petrona la
trabajadora humanitaria francesa
secuestrada durante cuatro años en mali
ya está en parís la mujer 75 años estuvo
en manos de grupos yihadistas y el
presidente manuel macro la recibió
personalmente a su regreso
de vuelta a su tierra natal luego de
cuatro largos años de estar secuestrada
sophie persona recibió una bienvenida
que normalmente es para los dignatarios
extranjeros en el momento en el que se
bajó del avión en el sur de parís ella
llegó con su hijo sebastián y el
presidente de francia de manuel majo lo
saludó junto con otros miembros del
gobierno
pero nada fue liberada al junto con el
líder opositor de malí suma las hice en
cuanto a ella se bajó del avión en la
capital de mali bamako cayó en los
brazos de su hijo quien únicamente se
arrepiente de no haber hecho más por
liberarla
y si lo mejor que pude
pero hiciste lo que pudiste hiciste lo
que necesitabas pero no fue suficiente
no te dije nadie es perfecto en este
módulo
la mujer de 75 años quien dirigía una
organización para huérfanos fue
secuestrada por los yihadistas en mali
en 2016 liberada junto a otros tres
retenidos persona fue la última francesa
secuestrada en todo el mundo ella le
dijo a los periodistas en bamako que
planeaba ir a francia oa suiza en un
tiempo cercano pero eventualmente espera
regresar a mali para continuar con su
trabajo de caridad cambiamos de
información y hablamos ahora de sudán
del sur el país más joven del mundo
porque el gobierno y varios grupos
rebeldes firmaron un histórico acuerdo
de paz en yubá después de 17 años de
conflicto armado que dejan miles de
víctimas fatales además las autoridades
anunciaron que se reunificarán las
fuerzas militares de acuerdo a lo
acordado en 2018 el próximo mes de
noviembre
[Música]
juba la capital de sudán del sur fue el
escenario de un histórico acuerdo un
gran número de delegaciones llegaron de
todas las partes que participaron y
traen con ellos la esperanza de un
futuro en paz alrededor de la mesa
integrantes del gobierno de transición
de sudan y del lado insurgente el frente
revolucionario de sudán una alianza de
cinco grupos rebeldes y cuatro
movimientos políticos de darfur kordofán
del sur y nilo azul pero hay algunos
ausentes dos movimientos insurgentes
declinaron la invitación durante el
evento el primer ministro sudanés les
envió un nuevo mensaje y todavía los
estamos esperando aunque se hayan
discutido de la mayoría de los temas
deben sumarse a este acuerdo de paz y
trabajaremos arduamente para llegar a un
acuerdo nacional integral bajo tony chan
un acuerdo de paz histórico en torno a
ocho prioridades la propiedad de la
tierra para permitir una redistribución
justa reparaciones y compensaciones a
las víctimas riqueza y poder compartidos
y el regreso de refugiados y personas
desplazadas
una reconciliación que también implica
el desmantelamiento de las milicias y
concesiones políticas hechas a los
insurgentes que se hicieron posibles
desde la caída del presidente del vecino
país de sudán omar al-bashir el año
pasado
otro punto importante es la integración
en el ejército regular hay sitios
adicionales en el consejo soberano que
supervisa la transición y también al
gobierno éste obtendrá el 25 por ciento
de los escaños en la futura asamblea una
paz que no se puede lograr sin el
regreso de las personas desplazadas de
darfur o la creación de una fuerza mixta
de dos mil hombres y su eficacia será
una de las pruebas determinantes para la
paz después de la polémica cerca del
código orgánico es una medicina contra
el coi 19 promovida por el presidente de
madagascar andry rajoelina ahora el
mandatario malgache lanzó un nuevo
tratamiento preventivo para esta
enfermedad en forma de cápsulas
desarrolladas por investigadores
nacionales una especie de código
orgánico de nueva generación a base de
arte inicia y aceites esenciales de
otras plantas medicinales de la isla
durante cinco meses escogido organiza ha
estado en el centro de la red
sanitaria contra el coi 19 en este país
insular
cápsulas naranjas color presidencial
salidas de máquinas brillantes este es
el último logro del presidente malgache
se veo plus un remedio preventivo contra
el hobbit 19 a base de artemisinina y el
aceite especial de revisar una planta
medicinal malgache frente a una
audiencia de altas personalidades el
presidente no escondió su orgullo en
cuanto a las preocupaciones sobre la
eficiencia rápidamente se dejan de lado
y hemos seguido los pasos los ensayos
clínicos y actualmente está
científicamente comprobado
hemos hecho todo lo que es una prueba de
efectividad inauguramos la fábrica que
es un orgullo nacional orgullo del
pueblo malgache y también orgullo de
áfrica
hace apenas unos meses las autoridades
apostaron por el hobbit orgánico
conocido como seve o un remedio
tradicional mejorado más artesanal a
base de artemisia distribuido
gratuitamente a los más vulnerables al
igual que en gone irina trabajadora de
32 años y madre de cuatro hijos más de
siete millones de malgaches han recibido
el famoso té de hierbas presentado como
una cura milagrosa contra el coronavirus
no tengo 1,50 euros para gastar ya no
puedo alimentar a mis hijos como esperan
que gaste 150 euros en cebo
si bien se supone que está en el centro
de la respuesta sanitaria el remedio se
ofrece como complemento de los
medicamentos convencionales no es
obligatorio para los enfermos siempre lo
distribuimos con otros medicamentos y le
explicamos a la gente llegan los
medicamentos y aquí está el cb o que nos
acompaña el presidente de madagascar
está convencido de ello
el cb o plus ha permitido limitar la
propagación del virus para este opositor
uno de los pocos que critica
abiertamente el remedio presidencial los
médicos están censurados
además hubo miedos hubo amenazas hubo
detenciones de profesores de medicina
alrededor de todo esto es por la que
esta es la razón por la que los
trabajadores de la salud tienen miedo de
discutir sobre seve
el objetivo del presidente es exportar
estas nuevas cápsulas anti kobe 19 a
todo el mundo
vamos ahora con información deportiva
aquí en áfrica siete días porque los
países africanos celebran dos nuevos
récords de atletismo en un mismo día un
ugandés rompió el récord masculino de
los diez mil metros y una etíope el
femenino de los cinco mil metros en la
misma competencia la valencia world
récords en españa
desde hace 15 años ya había logrado
batir la marca de también etíope
kenenisa bekele el periodo más largo en
esta competición
ahora la hazaña fue el ugandés joshua 7
tegui quienes cruzó la meta con un
tiempo de 26 minutos y 11 segundos 6
segundos después del récord que había
marcado bekele entre las mujeres la que
alcanzó esta hazaña fue la etíope let's
get it day quien marcó un nuevo récord
mundial de los 5000 metros con un
registro de 14 minutos y 6,62 segundos
casi 5 segundos por debajo del registro
previo que estaba en manos de su
compatriota y en vez de imbaba
escuchamos las palabras
vivimos en una situación difícil
ahora con el kobe pero estos eventos aún
pueden darnos alegría aún pueden darnos
esperanza para el mañana
coches y neveras sabiendo que debemos
tomar precauciones para derrotar al
virus debemos tener cuidado valor
estando activo
no es necesario volver a hacer
imprudentes y seguro que el mundo
volverá a la normalidad
no será fácil porque la mayoría de las
personas no están siguiendo las
precauciones y por lo tanto si queremos
volver a la normalidad lo mejor que
podemos hacer es que todos nos
preocupemos por cuidar animal
[Aplausos]
si esto es como un sueño que tenía desde
hace mucho tiempo y estoy muy feliz por
cómo terminó la competencia esto es muy
grande para mí por mí y finalizamos con
música y la cantante maliense aya
nakamura que se ha convertido en el
fenómeno musical de europa sus canciones
tienen millones de reproducciones y se
posiciona como un icono de la identidad
contemporánea del continente
después de su gran éxito mundial él ya
ya la cantante se ha convertido en una
voz contra el racismo y el machismo esas
son las imágenes de su más reciente
videoclip titulado scioli nana que hace
parte de su segundo álbum con ese
trabajo hay en la captura ha vendido más
de un millón de copias a nivel mundial
como uno de mí
si vivo
[Música]
m
pues con esta buena música
nakamura finalizamos este capítulo de
áfrica siete días ustedes por supuesto
pueden continuar con más en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom y
información en cuatro idiomas para
ustedes quédense con nosotros esto es
france24
como un mito
[Música]